what do you think of when I save the
South Texas Florida Alabama West
Virginia anything below Virginia paws
before you answer recognize the American
South has gone through a lot of changes
from house to find geographically to
trying to become its own nation to some
major demographic transformations so how
does all of that translate into who
chooses to identify as a southerner hey
Pam I me Mayan and this Sunday on aj+
we're unpacking the South its history
and how its evolved drastically over
time so get ready because we're about to
give you the sweet tea on southern
identity for a long time saying that you
were southern was synonymous with only
one identity as Professor H Gibbs not
explained six years ago it would have
meant probably or a white southerner and
kava bleeped you are a supporter of the
current racial structure where African
Americans were relegated to second-class
citizens and there were still people who
cling to this version of southern
identity and yet what it means to be
southern and seen as southern has
evolved but before we can talk about who
is a southerner we need to define where
the South is and that's been a point of
contention but still Florida is not the
south
probably would consider Florida South I
mean that's the South as you can get in
America
the Census Bureau breaks the United
States into four regions it defines the
South not just by Alabama and Georgia
but also includes Maryland Texas and the
nation's first date Delaware
yes really and there is another map of
the region that outlines how the South
has been divided historically by the
mason-dixon line it dates back to the
Civil War when states in the southern
part of the United States adamantly
disagreed with the rest of the Union on
slavery in those states agriculture
especially cotton was the engine of the
economy and slaves were the unpaid and
abused laborers that made it run slaves
were treated inhumanely they suffered
deadly beatings the decimation of their
families and forced labor without
compensation in many
were not allowed to learn to read or
write as the abolitionist movement
spread the North outlawed slavery and
pressured southern states to follow suit
but those states whose farming economy
was dependent upon slaves free labor
opposed ending the practice ending
slavery wouldn't just change their
economy it would change their entire way
of life because when you aren't paying
your labor force it makes a huge
difference to your revenue so the u.s.
went to war with itself and the United
States was torn into 11 states seceded
from the Union including Florida Alabama
Georgia Louisiana Texas Mississippi
Tennessee Arkansas South Carolina North
Carolina and Virginia these states were
serious about creating their own country
and keeping slavery the Confederate
States of America established their own
president and vice president as well as
their own flag including the Confederate
battle flag so it's this early division
in US history that solidifies the
identity of the Dixie South against
those Yankees the history dominated
southern identity for generations and
even influenced how the South history is
learned and told today there is a dark
side to southern identity it's someone
like Dylan Ruth the Charleston Church
here who back in 2015
killed nine individuals as they were at
a Bible study at Emanuel AME Church in
Charleston this tragedy caused South
Carolina to take the Confederate battle
flag down from the State Capitol
but today the conversation is also
focused on Confederate statues
supporters say these statues are to
remember southern history but in reality
they aren't only in the South they're
also in places like Los Angeles and
Washington State according to the
Southern Poverty Law Center most of
these monuments went up during periods
of extreme violence against black people
like at the height of the Jim Crow era
and the civil rights movement
some weren't even built as late as the
2010s now's a really great time to point
out Confederate commander Robert Ely
opposed erecting memorials to the losing
side in fact he wrote my conviction is
that however grateful would be to the
feelings of the south the attempt in the
present condition of the country would
have the effect of retarding instead of
it's accomplishment and of continuing if
not adding to the difficulties under
which the southern people labor while
new memorials have been erected some of
the older ones are coming down to
Confederate statues coming down
overnight in Lexington Kentucky where
removal work began quietly without
advance notice as the Sun set and
southern cities like New Orleans
Louisiana and Charlottesville Virginia
have decided to remove their Confederate
monuments those choices sparked fierce
rebuttals by white nationalists claiming
the removals are an attempt to erase
their history it's important to note
that books are a great place to learn
history the South's history also
includes the more than 55 percent of the
country's black population which lives
there and that has resulted in a shift
in who decides to identify as a
southerner Southern identity didn't seem
to be something that was driven by race
in the way that it was a few decades ago
blacks and whites were equally likely to
say they were southerners and that was
kind of one of our surprising and big
findings that's in large part to the
changing demographics in the south and
the movement of African Americans back
to the region after World War two many
African Americans left the cell to go
for better economic conditions to escape
discrimination since the 70s and
certainly going into the 80s there's
been a net migration of African
Americans back to the region many folks
are coming for some of the same reasons
other individuals new to the South for
economic opportunities there's a long
cultural connection to the region does
at least in part explain this strong
connection to the South and Southern
culture among African Americans but what
exactly is that culture and how is it
defined there's a lot of things that I
think no matter who you are people tend
to have pretty good agreement on it a
food manners hospitality a focus on the
geography and nature of the south and
southern states are believed to have a
particular set of politics the
stereotype is that they vote Republican
are socially conservative and go to
church I think people are increasingly
in this modern era that was kind of
building their own definition of what it
means to be a southerner and the South
at
as a region isn't becoming any less
powerful in fact it may be getting more
influential we see you North Carolina
that's growing this gaining
congressional seats and gaining
population given that younger folks are
equally as likely to connect with the
region and this tendency to want to
defend the region I think southern
identity and regional identity are
really here to stay
the South is more than a place a set of
people or politics
it's much more complicated we spend a
lot of time in the newsroom talking
about what makes up the south and how we
differentiate from me a key thing is
whether a place serves sweet tea or not
I'm team sweet tea what about you tell
us in the comments what you would like
us to cover next don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and we'll see you
next Sunday when we have another awesome
video and sweet tea is the only tea